está gravando acho que sim a luz está
piscando e aí a galera que aceite meu
canal tudo bom vocês eu estava de férias
nesta nova etapa por isso que eu estava
aqui agora no carnaval e ea naval
carnaval bocas é porque assim muita
gente não gosta de carnaval que ok você
pode não gostar não há muita gente gosta
também carnaval que é o que você também
pode gostar eu particularmente eu gosto
de toda aquela cor do carnaval eu gosto
muito é um que eu não goste carnaval é
que todo carnaval mesmo colher aquela
copa saber qual vai ser a música do
carnaval qualquer música do carnaval no
ano passado foi tratada a vingadora vão
lutar pra acelerou esse ano que tive foi
que te foi o turco tiro com a arma
próximo ano seu próprio satanás com uma
metralhadora na mão
todo mundo aqui dançando em um morro no
jogo é uma coisa também todo ano
transforma toda música em ritmo de
carnaval com música ei você aí a havana
na todo ano tem briga é o carro em cima
do teu tambon mulá que eu quero subir eo
mais alto e puder do humor jeito ninguém
lê o apoio liga no jornal neste carnaval
morreram apenas 350 pessoas e agora
vamos para o sport domingo o vasco
enfrenta o botafogo ou da sita ninguém
tocava se verificou e da cara tem muito
pra não está em salvador ficou pra
servir para mudar seu veículo da cerveja
metros é r$15 falei meu deus do céu eu
tô na imaginarium todo carnaval tem um
filho alguém que se perde henrique leva
a sério na hora de brincar carnaval e
leva o menino meio da rua e da folia e
da [ __ ] do carnaval é o mínimo que se
pede olha que como usá que eu quero
olhar mais alto olha aqui que eu puder a
pessoa tem sabor do baixinho
a banda vem baixando favor quando acham
agora aqui ó criança perdida aqui perto
do trio elétrico
pelo amor de deus gente que vou para
essa criança matou a minha é joaquim
à época contava grande perto amanhã dom
maroun um carro que cala catar no rio a
europa pronta que joaquim joaquim tac
perante a lei por favor que vou para
esse menino que buscam para esse menino
vai buscar - já que tá chorando aqui
gente que venha e foi responsável por
essa empresa por roubos caminho aqui
perto da casa de show olha que eu quero
sul e e [ __ ] se o menino lá para que
todo o carnaval na merda como tema veio
um carnaval só assim eu estava no
carnaval só assim o nome da loló
cadê o loló e aí eu sentia que ela leve
vontade é aquela pontada que a diarréia
ela tem três níveis e até aquela aquela
pontada que ela te dá para dizer assim
olha não tá tudo muito certo porque não
quer que você tem que se localizava a
procurar um lugar mais próximo eu
comecei a andar que pelo meio do povo
aqui sozinho aproveitando o ritmo da
galera que passou aqui no meio da galera
assim eu saí correndo comecei a hope
aqui todo dia ea hope ano sentimos
calafrio é o segundo livro da linha reta
mas sente calafrios e começa a hope a
experiência essa bagagem com a chegada
da televisão superior começa a subir
assim eu cheguei no banheiro público era
o banheiro público no banheiro químico
que o banheiro químico banheiro químico
é coisa engraçada e falar no fla
banheiro químico imagina o próprio
banheiro que faz a merda dele pega se um
negócio a porção enquanto aqui falar
agora vou criar um coletinho aaa até o
banheiro que maneira esse é o banheiro
público aquele banheiro que é muito
banheiro e é feito o tipo pela
prefeitura assim eu entrei já estava
aquela merda aquela miséria se sabe que
o banheiro público acho que o povo pensa
assim é público é apple carga na parede
essa merda contar na parede paulo curvo
sudesa pode bó adão entrei eu vi aquela
o estado do banheiro eu pensei que
alguém tinha ido cagar e explodiu aí eu
falei com o kaká aqui neste planeta todo
cagado média a mulher ela tem a técnica
a mulher sabe carregar no meio porque a
técnica chega aqui com um papelzinho faz
assim até um outro papel de um pai assim
apresentar assim pega mais um papelzinho
da enroladinho aqui ela bota perninha
pelo outro lado a taxa chega bem perto
assim ó gay aí eu comecei a dar aquele
terceiro avisa que a ré quando parece
que oculta mastigando chiclete que ele
não está agüentando mais a mastigar
chiclete ficção
a lei caimão você quer saber eu nem
passar por nenhuma não aí você tem que
ficar dando aquela aquela segurada sim
porque tipo assim uma etapa onde a ré se
você senta e você só tem tudo a ver e
fazer assim o foi por um banheiro
público pode ser que tenha alguém nos
outro lugar eu vou dar aquela
seguradinha aqui ok você a pressão você
aliviado o bota aqui ó aqui ó ficar
assim até que ela segurava só que assim
é o terror que não vai ter que assim se
eu tivesse outro lugar do mundo as
pessoas terem entendido talvez alguém
tivesse me oferecido uma pra cuba se
você está se sentindo bem eu me perdi a
minha mãe adora mas eu posso tanto que
até comprou um remédio funciona como eu
tava no nordeste só escutei isso aqui ó
segurança escutei assim em breve para
caco é atacar a mente é ligar a moto
aqui dentro mesmo jovem já no novo é
festa junina e raí terminou e tal eu
fiquei até meio receoso se eu falei cara
eu sentei naquela privada é nojenta tudo
só o bagaço aí tá lá eu fiquei merda não
acredito não anda nada não sebe
externado por acaso não podiam assistir
televisão de boa só assim eu incluí lo
aqui assistindo total da visão na beleza
não aconselhem assim consegui gostar ele
seja sincero foi comigo vocês se eu
coloco você gosta de mim é sincero não
se conseguir entrar no campo da rank
gostosa sim discutir em boston não é de
documento na no google não haverá linhas
em andradina na bernardino do anel mesmo
assim não se pega assim então os
conselhos você corre assim quer que é
gostoso cara de mora e você não consegue
coçar direito porque tem gente pega vai
passando devagar sem as pessoas vão
vacilando e você vai coçando a proteção
não faz só assim eu tô te falando mas
carnaval foi top lá é nené foi macio
carnaval ela achou me passando ali eu
mesma chamado loló e é bom que até os
conseguirem do grupo da vontade você e
por meio do deserto só para fazer assim
que gosto daquela coisa que o dia foi
passando e não passar e ficar com você
meu cunhado foi meu deu conta com sam
será que é porque o dep lei e passava de
coçando passar dicas antigo despertadora
consegue ocultar dormir de bobo eu
faltava era ouvido um dia vamos passar o
cozinha lembra que o tc está no banheiro
é isso já falei meu deus
elton e água no canal a minha mulher
falou na caneta não mãe é louis que foi
mãe eu tô com aquino cuma eu agoniado
meu deus do céu eu dei meu corpo vai
cair tal como eu aceitar pagar o que
fazer só eu pegar com a mão botafogo a
mãe não caiu mãe não caiu então mas com
lama ou cacon agora oito essa mensagem
que eu tenho pra você cuidar do carnaval
cuidado onde você sempre fui muito bem
no seu top view e antes de você sair
daqui e ir embora tem 14 coisa muito
importante pra falar pra você a primeira
quanto não esqueça de deixar o arica o
tom emocional porque eu cheguei aqui de
novo eu tô faz muito tempo que eu não
gostei a segunda coisa importante que eu
tenho pra você que várias pessoas que
assistiu vir não tá escrevendo no canal
você não tá escreve você está inscrito
você não vai fazer quando tem vídeo novo
irmão ou acalanto também é difícil nem
cineclick inscrever-se que está aqui
algum gravatá ela no meu deus parece um
bicho nova cabeleira terceira foi a
terceira coisa mais importante do meu
bebê como o show inteiro com o pai está
aqui no youtube para assistir está no
primeiro lucas que só não vê cosme chubb
fica a uma hora de choque e à costa pois
é importante eu não tenho mais chope com
já postei em meu show vocês estão tão
que inventar outro carro então fazem
show em são paulo agora do dia 16 bom 29
30 até uma data e um show que eu estou
falando sério vou testar piada por um
novo show que estou criando do texto
ampliado em são paulo há ingressos aqui
na descrição do vídeo tamo junto é nóis
e água que tem muitos filhos nove cinza
aí